en medio del llanto por la pérdida de
sus seres queridos familiares de las
víctimas del colapso de la línea 12 del
metro de la ciudad de mexico exigieron
justicia a un año del accidente que dejó
26 fallecidos y más de un centenar de
heridos
[Música]
en la vida de cristo
en la vida
queremos dejar huella que sólo vuelva a
pasar
[Música]
[Aplausos]
nosotros
[Música]
mañana pasa otra desgracia como ésta aún
no se ha detenido a ninguna persona la
fiscalía mantiene abierta la
investigación y la próxima audiencia
judicial será el 6 de junio pretende
acusar por homicidio y otros cargos a
diez personas entre ellas ocho
funcionarios públicos y dos empresarios
quiero volver a expresar mi solidaridad
absoluta con las víctimas y quiero
reiterar a las y los habitantes de la
ciudad de mexico que no descansaremos
hasta tener en operación la línea 12 del
metro con completa seguridad sin embargo
algunos de los familiares de las
víctimas llevaron el caso a la corte
suprema del estado de nueva york donde
impusieron una demanda civil contra las
empresas privadas que construyeron la
línea 12 los familiares piden que sea
demolido y se vuelva a construir pero el
gobierno local ha dicho que están
reforzando la infraestructura que se
extiende por más de seis kilómetros
esperan terminar los trabajos para
finales de este año